- Hey.
- What up, what up?
- There they go, sit down.
- What's up, man?
- Clean that seat out.
Y'all want something to drink?
Yeah, you do. Look like I'm
talking to two beer me, ain't I?
Huh?
Shit, that's--watch yourselves.
Anybody cut?
Everybody all right?
Okay, let me clean that up.
Watch your leg, Joey,
'cause
that glass can get in your skin,
and we can't get it out.
Brother, I got a new hobby, man.
- A hobby?
- Yes.
Mixology, man.
This is my new thing.
- Kev, you know you got to go to
school for bartending.
You know that, right?
- I don't have to go to school
for nothing, okay?
I took a app.
- An app?
- Yes.
Download a app on my phone,
mixology app,
read it for two minutes.
I got it all in my head,
brother.
Kev, people study for years to
become good bartenders.
You gonna learn from a app?
- Same people that study for
years are the same people
that created the app, so I don't
have to study for years, Harry.
- Give me a lemon drop.
- I don't--that's not in the
app.
I don't know what--I don't know
how to do that.
- All right, let me make it
simple.
Give me a gin and juice.
- Yes, that's easy.
That's easy.
- Are we talking about drinks
from the States,
or are you guys in Japan?
Where are y'all at?
Where do--let's talk about--
- The ingredients are in the
name, Kev.
- Brother, if I'm the
mixologist, let me mix, okay?
Let me--let me bring to you what
I do best.
Can we do that?
- Have at it.
- Huh?
Ooh.
Go boy.
Huh?
Is it a basketball, or is it a
bottle?
What do I have?
- Hey, man, just--
- Whoo.
- Huh?
- You want a long pour
or a short pour?
- I just want it in the glass.
- I'ma give you a long.
Uh-oh.
Still in the glass.
- Just-just--
- Still in the glass.
Who like dark?
I can't see nothing, 'cause I
like dark.
Boy, watch this.
Mm, hit 'em with it.
Splash that on 'em, right?
- You're getting--
- Brother, y'all like olives or
no?
Shit, grab that one for me?
- Don't--
- Pass it back to me.
I got you, brother.
- I'm not gonna do this.
- Saw this yesterday--Joey, come
here, Joey.
- I'm not gonna do it.
- Joey, brother,
let me show you
something.
I'm done, man. I can't.
- Just let me--come here.
Taste what I got.
Harry. Harry!
Joey! Huh?
It's called a Doohickey
Dirt Right.
That is fucking disgusting.